watch to the end of this video for an
epic surprise
this is the last tick tock video i'm
ever doing
one more and then we're done it's a sale
and we're cleaning out how let's
freaking
do this first off everyone's been
sending me this
i did this for pewdiepie if you're not
him keep scrolling that's me
here's no the [ __ ]
not at least i can respect if she does
that for a video
redemption complete
here's
[Music]
[Laughter]
redemption you are free you will now
pass the afterlife you're welcome
now no more no more time unfortunately
i can't be mixing with iffy the vibe and
40 on 50 is really the time why are you
all on my phone like you want me like
you wasn't pushing the kid to the side
[Music]
are you even trying anymore has
tick-tock just become me
you're becoming soft okay you're
becoming lazy gave me some original
things
please what are you pewdiepie
bumper
all right i'm glad it's over then i'm
glad this is the last
is he making fun of illiterate people
is that the same illiterate yeah it is
making fun of mute this
is so disrespectful
[Music]
oh my god
oh you're wondering why i'm laughing
because i can relate unlike you little
man let's
a little smurfs i'm actually tall okay
look how tall i am
i look down on you that's a freaking
point prove it
too late come on dude it's already in
motion
we'll put it out of motion you
pissed me off dan say something
something no say you piss me off
you pissed me off
oh my god that was absolutely incredible
people on tech talk are so talented i
wish i was talented like bang
you kiss me see i can't do it
damn it my eyebrow brings all the boys
to my page and they're like
what's on your oh no
nope i'm not looking at this thank god
it's the live stick
i'm over i'm over it i don't need this
anymore i'm done
you know what let's check what's on the
front page here we go
okay what have we got
[Music]
i'm not watching girls expectations
athletic sure
all right what next uh personality yeah
of course of course
of course classic all right that's fine
we can live without it
pay for dinner all right i guess one day
it's fine looks like a bowl what's under
here
oh pay for everything else too well yeah
we'll just throw that over here with the
ss relationship
uh oh while we're at it i keep up with
the daily drama that's fine let's just
turn this on
get it going a little bit of rain that's
fine what else do you want
do with kids i don't know why i need
that but we'll throw it in there
let's throw it in throw it in what else
do you want
commitment oh my oh that's fine
it'll be fine it's fine oh
it's sinking it's sinking i guess we're
done
are you kidding me sm edge it's so
unfair
you don't have any of those you're not
like this guy
[Music]
we're just friends
look we're just friends i don't care
i don't know anything about these people
full context let's keep watching
you absolutely i hope you get bitten by
raccoon get rabies and die a painful
death how could you not know that a
crafting table requires a diamond
how long have you been playing this
kid's game there's a reason your
girlfriend left you for ninja grow the
[ __ ] up
thanks for the five dollars it'll come
straight streamers gotta be like the
best
worst job ever it's such a grind and you
have to deal with all this
but you're still at the same time
playing games it's as if someone gave
you
gave like the devil gave you this uh
choice right you can play games for a
living
but also you're a streamer
oh god i'm a streamer now oh no follow
me on the
live come on guys
[Music]
oh my god
channel is so weird when youtubers and
whatever have
what is that called like the dating app
i do not
look like lele pons oh you want me to be
lately pond i could be
like when you um when your
[ __ ] homework is due
lollipop is latina did you know about
this has anyone ever told you dude
all i want to know is is lily puns going
to be
in 2019 rewind that's all i care about
nothing else matters this ever happened
to you
i'm gonna teach you how to take them off
step one
step two
just buy it has this ever happened to
you
isn't it so annoying when you try and
steal something
and i guess sometimes they forget to
pull it off i get that
moving on last tick tock guys let's get
excited for the last and surprise at the
end xbox remember
besides there's no army in the world i
would rather give you watch time
it's been a while right so while i can
still be heard
here's one last breakfast from the
number one
don't do it don't do it
god it makes me so anxious i thought it
would break the tv i never know what
people are going to do these days
fix your cables you call that cable
management
what the freaking [ __ ] disgusting
might as well smash your teeth
if you're a woman you might want to keep
scrolling unless you want to get a lady
boner
in three two
[Music]
[Applause]
all these useless talents somehow people
get value out of it
thanks to me
[Music]
check out this cool lamp thing i wonder
what would happen if i rubbed it
you have summoned me a magical genie
now tell me the first of your wish is
three oh
sweet um i wish that all genies had
small dicks
why now why would you do
that i wish that all genies had overly
its large nipples
last tick tock video
declaration of independence so
now man
that is the saddest thing i've ever seen
in my life declaration
of independence how could you do this
shake my head never been so disappointed
[Music]
oh ben shapiro
you finally woke up
why did you invite me to your bar
mitzvah ben
i'm so confused why ben
why i'm gonna check with ben shapiro and
make this right
how could you do this ben how could you
not invite her to bar mitzvah
oh benjamin
this is ben shapiro is a baby that
hasn't invited
her to the bar mitzvah roleplay you
finally woke up
why did you invite me to your
that's the best tick tock i've seen okay
that was it that's all for tech talk
forever thank you guys
we made it this far 100 episodes
absolutely
incredible if you enjoyed check out
merch and i'll see you guys
tomorrow what youtuber simulator is
becoming relevant
no no don't leave
no please sponsor eagle please do
something
yes
this game is still relevant damn it
there's no surprise